uh oh
looks like somebody left the gas running
on jupiter
don't do anything stupid like
lighting a humongous match
what would a match need to be made of to
ignite this gas giant
how big would it have to be
and how much damage would this explosion
do to our solar system
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you lit a match on jupiter
[Music]
okay you've heard me say this before
jupiter is the largest planet in our
solar system
it's 300 times more massive than earth
but it's less dense than our home
with no solid surface this planet is
almost entirely gaseous it has an
atmosphere composed of 90 hydrogen about
10 helium and trace amounts of methane
and ammonia
with so much hydrogen present
pretty much all of jupiter must be
flammable right
so
if you lit a match
how much of that wooden stick would burn
off before it all goes
kaboom
okay before you go ahead and strike that
match there's one big catch you didn't
account for
fire
needs oxygen
without any oxygen in jupiter's
atmosphere it would be impossible for
the planet to erupt in flames
not only that but lighting your match
would be
difficult to say the least
now if you're watching this video
without a vpn you're already playing
with fire
so before you blow up your browser check
out our sponsor atlas vpn
atlas vpn does more than hide your
location their data breach monitor
protects your personal information from
getting into the wrong hands like the
one holding this match
hey put that down and listen up because
right now atlas vpn is running a huge
discount you can get a three-year
subscription for just 139 a month with a
30-day money-back guarantee yeah that's
right three full years of blazing fast
internet speeds and protection on all
your devices
keep your data safe from the weirdos on
the internet
click on the link in the video
description below to lock in this rate
with a 30-day money-back guarantee
[Music]
something burning
usually when you drag a matchstick
across the red strip on your matchbox
you start a series of small chemical
reactions that end in a flame
when you apply friction to the box red
phosphorus converts to white phosphorus
this mixes with the oxygen in the air
and ignites
without oxygen this ignition wouldn't
happen
but since you're so determined to set
jupiter on fire you'd have to find a way
around this obstacle
for starters you'd need to reinvent the
matchbox
you'd need one that could ignite the
match without the need for external
oxygen in the atmosphere
so you could lose the white phosphorus
in your match
instead you'd need a match that could
generate enough heat from friction to
break down potassium chloride on the
matchstick into oxygen
the flame would keep burning as long as
the matchstick coating lasted
but one matchstick wouldn't provide you
with the oxygen you'd need to ignite
jupiter
you'd need a lot more
again considering that jupiter is the
most massive planet in our solar system
you'd be burning off an astounding
amount of hydrogen
to be precise about
1.4 multiplied by 10 to the power of 27
kilograms of the stuff
for hydrogen to combust you'd need about
half as much oxygen present in the
atmosphere as there is hydrogen
as you might have guessed you'd need to
gather a lot of oxygen and because
molecules of oxygen are way heavier than
molecules of hydrogen the total mass of
oxygen we'd need would be about six
times the mass of jupiter
yeah there isn't enough oxygen in the
entire solar system for this to happen
sorry to disappoint you but uh jupiter
won't be erupting in flames anytime soon
and before you try to get creative with
your methods let me tell you that even
the most energetic impact that ever
occurred on the gas giant didn't cause a
single spark
in 1994 the comet shoemaker levy 9
crashed into jupiter
as it entered the atmosphere it broke
into multiple pieces
some were as large as one kilometer in
diameter
the total impact of all these pieces was
massive
so massive that the total kinetic energy
was many times more powerful than the
hiroshima nuclear bomb
but still
no flames
still feeling destructive
well maybe you could see what would
happen if jupiter and saturn collided
but
that's a story
for another
what if